Film Courage: Keith can you explain
virtual production workflow?
Film Director/Producer/Writer/Owner of Sutliff
Studios – Virtual Productions, Keith Sutliff:
Virtual production is a little bit different than
the normal filmmaking process and it starts what
we call previz [pre visualization]. A client
will come to us and say Hey I want to do this
project in virtual production so everything in
virtual production is done in that pre-production
process there's a lot of planning so I one of the
questions we ask them is well what are you trying
to achieve and what are some different ways
we can achieve it because not every not every
virtual production shoot requires what we call a
3D asset which is using Unreal Engine and there's
also called 2D assets which we use as well which
is a video or image plates which basically for
people who don't know what that is is basically a
video file or image file which's displayed on the
LED wall so and that can kind of parallel with
in camera view effects which I can get to get
into later but anyways so if a person comes to
us they're like hey we want to do this we start
talking about okay what are we going to use 2D
asset 3D asset do we need camera tracking with the
3D asset Unreal Engine and depending on what they
need we'll make that determination so we start
planning it out help them out with decorating the
foreground with whatever practicals they need to
sell that environment like if they're in the snow
mountains where to get a proper set dresser person
to come in and we help facilitate that so we
talk about all these different things and like
talk about the certain camera they're using and
the technical elements that what's involved in
virtual production not just in camera what you can
see but also with the blocking and placements of
the actor compared to the wall depending on what
shots they want so a lot of that stuff discussed
in the previz in pre-production and we shoot in
virtual production since everything is with an
LED walls a backdrop versus a green screen it's
all shot in what we call picture so when you're
in postproduction you don't have to worry about
compositing and taking that green screen out
putting whatever back background you want in
there it's all shot in the can so that's one
of the big benefits so so yeah so so everything's
shot there it saves them a lot of time so we talk
about all these elements and when it's time for
the shoot they come in we tech advise and help
them out with all those different things I just
discuss and we decorate with the right foreground
dressing depending on the scene right and we light
it properly for the shots they want and the proper
lens focal length if they want like a tighter shot
on a 50 or 65 millimeter or if they're trying to
get a wide shot which can be achieved well on for
production just there's more precise blocking what
has to be done we help them out with that so
that's a lot of technical stuff that we help
out with so we get them what they want and then
if they're using the Unreal Engine we'll if they
want camera tracking to create that parallax we
help them out with that as well so if they're just
using a 2d U asset such as a video image plate
then it doesn't have camera tracking on it so
just depends what they need so that's kind of the
whole process works with virtual production and
then they then have that footage they can take to
go into post direction it's all shot in picture so
they don't have to do any compositing but all that
previous work is done up front for pre-production
where all those things I just discussed have to
be precisely talked about so it's lit properly
they have the right focal length millimeter 50
or 65 mm wherever it's a tighter shot or it's a
wider shot whatever they're trying to achieve
so so yeah they take that in post production
and they have we give them something good what
they want for their project so that's kind of
the whole process from virtual production how it
kind of works from being then but but yeah I know
I talked a lot about the 2Ds like a video image
play but in camera effects can kind of parallel
with virtual production so I can go into that as
well but we do both and can someone use their own
DSLR camera yes and no so I tell people I have a
guide I give out to people for cinematographers
who come in I recommend strongly a cinema camera
a film camera when you come into a virtual studio
where has shutter angle and different things on it
for settings DSLRs I don't recommend for various
reasons there's very few settings we work on a
DSLR not if at all depends on the camera on the
DSLR but there's very few settings will work on
DSR camera so myself my team we don't recommend
those bring cinema camera into our studio or
I'd recommend that to any virtual studio so
yeah and and I'm assuming no no iPhones yeah
so also so now good question now phones also
like phone cameras you're going to have a
lot of issues with as well in these issues
I'm talking about you'll see we call banding
(horizontal banding) and flickering there's
different terms in the in virtual production in
the VFX community for this some people call like
line tearing and flickering horizontal banding
but you're going to see different elements and
you're going to see a lot of that with a phone
camera you can't get around it unless you can
adjust some certain settings what need to
be done especially with a cinema camera what
that can offer so what phones don't offer so yeah
you're going to see issues with the phone camera.
Film Courage: Can you explain what is parallax?
Keith: Sure, parallax. Basically in virtual
production we have our 3D asset which is Unreal
Engine if you have Unreal Engine and you're going
to have a a camera tracker what gets mounted on
the top of the camera and depending on the type
of camera tracking solution you're using you're
going to have it depends like if you're using
Moses you're going to have these little star
these little reflectors on the ceiling there's
different there's different companies would offer
different things or they might have like a base
stations these there's another camera tracking
solution has they call them base stations and it
receives a signal they all operate this similar
they receive a signal to the camera tracker
and that camera tracker gets tied in unison
with a in-game camera so there's an actual camera
inside Unreal Engine we call a c camera actor and
that's through a a plugin in Unreal Engine ties
both of those in unison so the camera tracker
and the in-game camera so when it's tied together
basically when you move your camera tracker on top
of the camera it's the screen we call parallax in
it's shifting it's it's moving it's it's changing
perspective so if you're panning left or right
it's the environment is going to pan left or
right so if your actor or your subject in front
is moving left or right when the camera tracker
when the camera is moving left or right it's going
to move with it so it creates that real 3d effect
that you're actually there versus a static image
so that is the definition of Parallax and kind of
how it works what it is and what's involved what
is realtime rendering sure real-time rendering is
basically creating assets on the fly so like
if you're going to create a 3D assets Unreal
Engine what we call it you're creating it on the
spot so you are either creating that environment
on the spot or you're moving objects in the
background and Unreal Engine on the spot so
everything's done when we call in real time which
means immediately so if you want to change like
mountain ridges if you want to change waterfalls
in this background or like buildings anything you
can move them around you can delete them you can
change the sunlight direction you keep it in the
sunlight in a certain area at all times but it
can be changed in like I said what we call real
time immediately so you can change things in real
time and you can you can create the environment
on the spot if you want me'll take some time like
if you're usually an asset like a 3D asset Unreal
Engine it's going to be created way in advance
but you can move things out in and out in the
game program immediately so in real time so that's
one of the big benefits but that's generally what
it is so you have that that computer gaming
Software System what's you're changing things
you're creating things on the spot so that's why
it's so beneficial real-time rendering you're
creating things on the Fly for what you want for
the production they're like hey I don't want that
Mountain Ridge there I want to have this there I
want that building moved over here you just change
it right there in a split second and that's
it what about in post production m can you do
the same or no once you've shot the image it's
there to stay well there's a lot of things you
can do in post- production now so I mean I would
say yes it depends on who who your VFX guy is in
post-production I mean you can do a lot of stuff
but I mean the whole purpose of virtual production
and rear projection with LED walls is it's all
shot in the can it's all shot in picture so you
don't have to do that you don't have to do a lot
of work in post- production but I mean if you're
hire the right person and you're like hey I don't
I changed I don't like that mountain ridge in the
background I mean I'm sure they can work some
magic to get it out I've never done that I I
mean I don't we don't we don't really do that for
the post- production work we just deal with the
virtual production aspect but but yeah how do you
match the lighting especially with people in front
of the screen and then what's on the screen sure
yeah so the lighting that's one of the biggest
elements would help sell virtual production and
you have to be very careful on how you light most
cinematographers we guide them when they come here
and they'll figure it out but we we Tech VI and
all that so you're going to match your lighting
sources so if you have like say you're like in an
alleyway or something in a three environment
or Unreal Engine or whatever even the video
image plates you're going to match your lighting
Source if you have like a street light coming from
like over here you're going to match that and say
it's like a neon light well you're going to put a
neon light over here and try to match as best as
possible so you really just try to it's not too
technical I mean it seems it but you just match
what's on the LED wall wherever your lagging is
coming from sunlight or wherever you put that sun
that that Lighting in the same area to come down
on your subjects so that's how you kind of light
it so there's different elements and wherever else
is needed to sell that you're in environments can
you tell us about using virtual production to take
advantage of golden hour well I can remember
as myself going on locations and filming and
having to worry about rushing to get that shot off
because of the sun's running out you're running
out time you want that specific look with the sun
in a certain direction for your environment but
with this virtual production is you don't have to
worry about that at all because the sun can now
be manipulated to stay in the same exact direction
for the whole time you're there essentially or it
can be moved it can be taken out you can make
it nighttime but you can make it that golden
hour the whole time the whole 12 hour day if you
want for how many scenes you want so that's one
of the big benefits of having it versus is like
hey I only have 30 minutes to get the shot now
you have 12 hours or however long you're in the
studio how does virtual production impact travel
costs yeah that's well huge because now with the
virtual Studio everything's shot in the studio
you don't have to travel anywhere you just go to
the studio and the cast and crew doesn't have to
travel 2 hours to get to the mountains or deserts
or wherever the location is if you want to shoot
an indoor location a mountain ridge location like
a desert location one day you can do that so you
just go to the virtual studio and everything
can literally be changed on that LD wall in a
matter of seconds if you're using Unreal Engine
or even a video image plate changed in a second
so so yeah you don't have to travel two hours
to get to these locations you can do everything
right there and that's where it cuts down on your
production time literally in half so instead of a
12-day shoot you're doing a six- day shoot because
now you just did a a shot on the skyscraper of New
York your next scene is indoors somewhere and then
now you're out mountain in the mountains the snowy
mountains doing some snow scene it's all shot
right there wherever the studio is at and what
about the fact that as filmmakers start using this
technology that maybe a lot of films will have
the same backgrounds well well yes and no I mean I
mean they can I mean so Unreal Engine you can make
you can make these backgrounds so whoever either
yourself or whoever your team is either your
team makes it or you can source through another
contractor who makes Unreal Engine backgrounds
so yeah either you make it yourself or another
contractor whoever there's different ways there's
a Marketplace you can get them as well so royalty
free commercial free so yeah so there's constantly
new new environments being made or like I said
you make yourself and if you're using a 2d asset
such as a video image plate you can go film those
yourself shoot them yourself or you can go online
too and get royalty free stock free images or
video files to to use so there's there's tons of
ways to keep getting the files and making them so
yeah so the possibilities are endless that you're
not going to be sort of like there's not going
to be a hundred templates and everyone's going
to have the same thing right because essentially
with Unreal Engine I mean they're always making
there's so many different assets and things
where constantly being made that you can get for
yourself or make it yourself you can constantly
it's endless possibilities and same with video
image plates you can go and shoot those yourself
or get it from somebody else so yeah there's no
like I'm I'm not worried about it I know a lot of
other filmmakers they shouldn't be worried about
like seeing the same backdrop for like different
movies and stuff because anything can be made it
doesn't matter what it is you just design it from
scratch.